ماذا فعلت اسرائيل امام مطالبه اعلى سلطه
قضائيه في العالم لها بالكف عن ممارسات
القيام بها يجعلها تقع ضمن تعريف الاباده
الجماعيه القتل ثم القتل ثم
القتل قتلت اسرائيل منذ الجمعه الماضي يوم
صدور حكم المحكمه في لاهاي وحتى اليوم
اكثر من
فلسطينيا واصابت
1800 فضلا عن عدد من المفقودين لا حصر له
ممن قضوا تحت
الانقاض قتلت اللائذين من القصف بدور لم
يعد فيها امن ولا
سلامه قتلت المحتمين بالمستشفيات يظنون
انها اماكن لها حرمه لكن وقائع الحرب التي
توشك ان تكمل شهرها الرابع اثبتت ان لا
حرمه لمكان عند جيش الاحتلال الاس
اسرائيلي تماما كما كانت المدارس والمساجد
والكنائس كلها اهدافا
للقصف لقد استمرت عمليات القصف الاسرائيلي
دون توقف في جنوب قطاع غزه وهو الجهه التي
اوهمت قوات الاحتلال المواطنين بانها امنه
فكانت المجزره بعد المجزره تؤكد زيف ادعاء
الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي حول كل ما في
القطاع الى اهداف شفنا بعض الجثث المحلله
والمرميه واللي تم تصفيتها في
المكان بعد سبعه ايام من قرار المحكمه لم
يتغير شيء في السلوك العسكري لجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ضد الفلسطينيين في
غزه لم يتوقف
القتل تواصل اسرائيل هجومها على ما تبقى
من النظام الصحي في غزه وذلك بقصف محيط
المستشفيات التي بقيت تعمل جزئيا في خان
يونس جنوبي القطاع
فتستهلك نحو ما يحدث في مستشفى ناصر
الحكومي ومستشفى الامل التابع للهلال
الاحمر
الفلسطيني توشك الدائره الجهنميه ان تكتمل
لافناء الفلسطيني باباد ته باكثر من طريقه
واحده للقتل فمن لم يمت بالقصف والرصاص
المصبوب على جسده مات بالهدم تحت
الانقاض سيموت اخرون بانعدام الدواء
والخدمه الطبيه حين لا يعود في غزه مف
يعمل وسيموت مئات بل ربما الاف من
الفلسطينيين جوعا وهم يتوسطون امه عاجزه
عن
نجدتهم من سيبر نفسه يوم سقوط النساء
والاطفال والرجال من
الجوع فعدم وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
ومنها الطعام لا يعني شيئا غير الموت
للاسف نحن يعني امام يعني مجاعه حقيقيه
ممكن ان نتج الى امام مجاعه حقيقيه الحال
كذلك يبقى السؤال الاكثر احراجا من سيتصدى
للاستهانة
فلسطينين القمه العربيه الاسلاميه لم
تتجاوز وقفتها المتضامنه مع غزه الدعوات
الى وقف اطلاق النار وهي دعوات لا شفيع
لها من
[موسيقى]
قوه وحدها جنوب افريقيا التي ساقت اسرائيل
ال محكمه العدل الدوليه قالت على لسان
وزيره
خارجيتها انها بصدد اقتراح فرض اجراءات
اخرى على المجتمع الدولي في مسعاها لمنع
اسرائيل من الاستمرار في قتل المدنيين في
غزه جيد ان في العالم جنوب
افريقيا انها تقلل بشاعه العالم بلزومها
الحق كما لا يفعل
غيرها